une entrevue dans un quartier paisible
de rio avec un québécois d'origine
brésilienne de retour au pays natal
nous parlons des difficultés du
président jacques bolson arrow la
commission parlementaire d'un kg est
sur la commune 19 un homme s'approche
écoute et se plante dans laxe de la
caméra l'homme soupçonnent qu'on
critique jaillir ball sonar où il se
fâche
nous décidons de laisser rouler la
caméra très vite il dit qu'il exige le
retour des forces armées pour régler le
problème nous allons répéter 1964
immédiatement dit il c'est l'année du
début de la dictature militaire
ismaël ne cache pas ses opinions de
gauche et c'est l'altercation
c'est un ancien militaire il dit que
toute l'armée dernière boule sonar ou
des passants s'arrêtent perplexe nous
reprenons l'entrevue un peu plus loin
que c'est comme ça le brésil aujourd'hui
oui c'était dit viser vraiment
il ya des - de - déjà commis la
situation est d'autant plus tendue que
la police civile de l'état de rio vient
d'effectuer un raid anti trafiquants
dans la favela de jacarezinho qui a fait
29 morts dont un policier
un record de violence on soupçonne le
président d' encourager ce genre
d'opération les combats au trafic de
drogue aux trafiquants ces progrès de
l'espace pour les milices dans les
favelas ces colères qu il ya en
sympathie des bons scénarios pas
seulement avec l'armée mais elle m'a
aussi avec la milice de la milice c'est
des groupes armés illégaux qui
contrôlent des territoires ou are you
plusieurs milices sont liés sont des
militaires ex militaires mais les
milices ne sont pas l'armée quelle
proportion de militaires sont des
nostalgiques de la dictature pure et
dure qui a dominé le pays pendant 20 ans
probablement autant que dans la
population générale que notre analyste
estime à 25 à 30%
mais qu'en est il des hauts gradés
lederne les forces armées le des
généraux de régime est fini à 40 ans ce
sont des gens qui sont se sont
développées dans leur carrière pendant
les régimes démocratiques
et ils ont semble-t-il résister à une
possible tentative de coup d'état
militaire de la part de jaillir ball
sonar ou qui menacent à tout bout de
champ d'appeler l'armée pour faire plier
le congrès les maires les gouverneurs et
la justice sa rhétorique qui menace la
dynamique démocratique deux pays le 29
mars dernier surprise générale le
ministre de la défense fernando azevedo
et silva démissionne ou et limogés sans
explication j'ai toujours été
entièrement loyal se borne t il à dire
le lendemain c'est au tour des trois
généraux à la tête de l'état major des
armées de démissionner ils ont été et
sont commencé à percevoir qu'ils étaient
en train d'être utilisé par bon sens la
roue en tant que tu as une arme contre
l'opposition contre bonsoir ou appelle
l'armée
mon armée et ils ont du ballon on n'est
pas votre âme et on a alarmé du brésil
on est là pour faire la politique n'est
pas l'interprétation du président du
club militaire du brésil le général
eduardo barbossa il ne sait pas dans
quelles circonstances le ministre est
parti mais il affirme que si l'état
major a démissionné c'est parce que le
nouveau ministre de la défense et d'un
rang inférieur au leur il n'y a pas une
rébellion affirme-t-il les membres du
club dont plusieurs dirigeantes était
président de la république sont des
militaires ou des ex-militaires gerbe
also know en est membre mais le klube
expriment des opinions politiques
conservatrices et chrétienne dit le
général barbossa mais indépendante de
l'armée ou du gouvernement
ces principes qu'à l'égalité éthique et
moralité le général visiblement proche
du président molson arrow et il ne cache
pas sa nostalgie pour l'époque de ladite
est
mais pas sur la question politique
assure-t-il tso3 image moderne dans
stahl giddins brésil qui s'est
modernisée qui était sécuritaire du
général pas corrompu comme l'est selon
lui toute la gauche brésilienne
l'an dernier des milliers de personnes
ont manifesté à l'occasion du 55e
anniversaire du coup d'état militaire du
31 mars 1964 il rappelait que 434
brésiliens ont été assassinés par le
régime militaire qui pratiquait la
détention arbitraire et la torture
d'opposants ils protestaient parce que
jaillir ball sonar aux arrêts institué
la commémoration du coup d'état abolie
sous la présidence de dilma rousseff
à cette occasion le général luis eduardo
batista pereira c'est donc je serai
soldats la presse sera libre et
démocratique
un thème sans nul doute aux élections
présidentielles d'octobre 2022